[Music]
today's question comes from helen in
michigan she says i'm looking to build a
home i have enough save for 20 down and
have no debt with current wait times
should i wait to build until prices
start to come down or should i go ahead
and start the building process before
mortgage interest rates go up more as i
heard they are going up soon
all right fair question there from helen
well i don't like making decisions based
on what might happen and so i feel like
if she's got the money to do this right
now go ahead and start the process
nothing wrong either way um
you know there's no question that
there's a shortage of labor right now in
the building world and that the building
material prices have still not
adjusted
back to reasonable uh after covid some
of them have i mean lumber went way up
and then it's back down
it's not all the way down though um and
so i think you're going to see some
smoothing out of
the cost of the house could be offset by
the increase in interest rates which we
have seen it
interest rates actually tick up
uh how much more are they going to take
up i don't know and is it going to
offset the cost savings so it's
completely up to you i can tell you this
building a home today at this moment if
you broke ground today in most cities is
going to be more stressful
because you're going to have shortage of
stuff shortage of labor
and uh and it's going to you know it's
just going to take a little longer to
build the house it's going to have a
stress factor to it that is very real
you got to watch watch it like a hawk
you got to be keeping up and there's
going to be things that go wrong they
don't get right and so it's it's a side
project exactly so you know it just
depends on how happy you are on this you
know i mean but there's not a there's
not like oh don't do it now no matter
what or you gotta go right now you know
neither one you you're okay whichever
one you feel best about you're probably
going to
you might see a little higher interest
rate and a little cheaper price
and a little smoother build
if you wait
if you're willing to go ahead and do it
now you've got more known factors to
george george's point we're not gonna
we're not doing what we're gonna worry
about might happen we kind of know yeah
where you are right now and now with
interest rates dave you've seen them
where they're skyrocketing
right now if they go up we're not
talking eight ten percent yeah no
they're not you know they're at what
four percent somewhere around there
right now so we're not going to see
i mean if we did it'd be highly unusual
uh the number of times in 30 or 40 years
that i've seen interest rates move
more than one or two percent in a year
is highly unusual and so you just you
know you're gonna see quarter eight that
kind of stuff movement
um and we've already seen that a little
bit but it's just it's this little tick
but it does but it does change the
payment i mean it does change
you know what it costs you to buy the
house